good morning Hank it's Thursday December
17 2009 time for the project for awesome
I got too excited about the awesome and
no as it happens I'm not wearing any
pants this is YouTube not a Country Club
the project for awesome is an annual
event in which the YouTube community
comes together to make videos about
charities we care about and then we rate
and favorite and comment upon those
videos to get them to rise to the top of
the YouTube pile if you've made a
project for awesome video go ahead and
upload it as a response to this video
but regardless of whether you've made a
video head over right now to livestream
comm slash project for awesome which for
the next 48 hours will be your
headquarters for awesome
we're organizing the project for awesome
through livestream this year because
even though it isn't perfect it allows
everyone to be in the same room at the
same time and all you need to chat is a
Twitter account if you don't have a
Twitter get one if you hate Twitter just
get one and then burn it in 48 hours so
please hang out at the chat as much as
possible it allows us to organize our
comments and rates and favorites so that
a roving band of nerds can take over the
largest entertainment website in the
world Hank
nerdfighters I'll see you in the
comments of hundreds of videos in the
next couple days and now my project for
awesome video hi my name is John Green
my wife and I are about to have our
first baby well I mean I guess she's
gonna have it I'm gonna stand there next
to her and then faint and when I told
everybody that we were gonna have a baby
a lot of people offered to get us a baby
warming present but our particular
unborn baby is extremely well equipped
on the baby stuff front he's got a
changing table he's got a puppy he's
even got a train set but there is one
thing that my unborn child does
desperately want an end to malaria you
see my unborn baby hates malaria in fact
sarin I recently went in for an
ultrasound and what they do is they put
this wand on the stomach and you can see
the baby and hear the heartbeat and you
can also hear what the baby is saying so
we were listening to the heartbeat for a
while and then the ultrasound technician
went up to the baby's mouth and the
first words I heard my unborn baby say
were oh because I'm stopping for them on
the other car but you and I aren't stuck
inside of amniotic sac so we can do
something about malaria and to that end
I'm going to be auctioning off these my
nerd glasses which I wore for almost
every vlog brothers video in 2008 you
can find a link to the auction in the
sidebar all proceeds go to malaria no
more also if you want to get my baby a
present you can go to first giving calm
slash John's baby hates malaria
donate to malaria no more on behalf of
my malaria hating unborn child nerd
glasses I'm gonna miss you but I'm sure
you're going to a nerd fight astok home
happy project for awesome and
nerdfighters dftba em don't forget to
beat all malaria